翻訳: Koji Nagai
校正: Hiroko Kawano
人は生物進化の頂点にあります
でも もうひとつ 重要な生物がおります
これも 別の意味で
生物進化の頂点に立っています
その生物は昆虫です
今日は その昆虫の存在が我々
あるいは我々が住む地球の環境に
どういう意味があるかについて
考えてみたいと思います
昆虫の祖先は海から上がってきました
同時にその頃に 魚が両生類になって
陸上に上陸してきました
魚の方の系統は
体がどんどん大きくなっていって
人とか哺乳類といった
[大きな]動物になっていきました
それは何かというと
体が大きいということは
内的な安定性といったものが
実現されるからです
昆虫は逆の方向に向かっていき
小さな動物になるように
進化をしていきました
体が小さくなって同時に
海の中でエラで呼吸していたものが
陸上に上がって来て
気管系という呼吸系を作りました
非常に効率の良い
酸素の伝達・運搬手段です
ですから体の中に
私達のような毛細血管ではなくて
細かい気管が走っている
しかも細胞まで直接酸素が運ばれて行く
というシステムです
そこで理の当然として
昆虫は翅（はね）を持って
空に飛び立って行った訳です
空に飛び立って行くということは
地球上に色んな生物が棲んでますけど
あらゆる所に飛んで行って
そこにランディングをして
自分たちで自分たちの生活を
切り開くこともあるし
他の植物や動物達や
そういったものとの
緊密な生物間相互作用を
作り上げて行きました
例えば 花をつくる植物—
顕花植物といいますが
顕花植物は昆虫を誘導するために
綺麗な花を作ったり蜜を出したり
そういうことで自分たちの繁殖を
昆虫に依存するように進化してきました
昆虫を嫌いな方も
一杯いらっしゃると思いますけど
それを 例えば「全部撲滅してしまえ」
ということになると
地球環境が段々おかしく
なっていきます
最近の例では ミツバチが
巣から居なくなるという現象がありました
ミツバチに受粉を依存している植物は
実が実らなくなるし
多くものは 農作物ですね—
果樹とかそういったものが
そういうものが実らなくなっていく
そういう問題が起こりました
それから 動物や植物の屍体なんかも
昆虫が全部片付けてる訳ですから
昆虫が居なくなるとそういうものが
周りに溢れてしまいます
それから シロアリのお腹の中には
微生物がいて
直接窒素を固定するということで
シロアリが例えばいなくなると
地球環境の空気の組成も
変わってしまいます
そういうことで
昆虫というものは
我々にとっても
非常に重要な役割を果たしています
次の話は そういう環境における意味
だけではなくて
昆虫が実験動物として非常に役に立つ
という側面についてお話しをしたいと思います
ここに出てくる「ゴキ君」は
嫌われ者でヒール（悪役）ですが
今日のお話のヒーローであります
このゴキブリで
皆さん 「体内時計」という言葉を
お聞きになったことはありますか？
生物時計とかそういうものは
私たちの体の中にもあるんですが
その体内時計の「座」
どこにあるか？ということは
このゴキブリの研究で初めて解りました
ではどうしてゴキブリで
体内時計が解ったか？というと
このゴキブリというのは
非常に強靭な生命力を持っています
首を取っても歩いているし
腹を取っても歩いているし
脳をざくざく切っても
平気で動いています
別の個体の脳の一部を取ってきて
植え付けてやると
それでちゃんと繋がって機能します
（笑）
そういうことで 強靭な生命力というものが
１つのキーワードになるかと思います
それから昆虫の神経細胞というのは
大きくて数が少なくてシンプルですね
それから突起が神経細胞にはあるんですが
それを切ってもすぐに繋がってきます
そういう 生物の実験をやる上で
非常に便利な側面があるということです
そういうことで 1960年前後に
ゴキブリの頭の中に生物時計がある
ということが解りました
その後色々な動物で
生物時計のありかが知られていって
今では色々な生物
単細胞生物からヒトまで
そういう生物時計があって
そこで働いている遺伝子が
昆虫とヒト[に]共有されている
といった現象が知られてきています
ですから昆虫とヒトが生きている原理は
非常に近いんだ
私たちは はじめ
生物時計を調べるつもりで
脳を開けて脳にメスを入れていました
そうしたら
奇妙なことが起こったんです
特定の—この真ん中のところなんですが
脳を切ってやる
そしてそれを暗闇の中で飼ってやると
この左の方は普通に食べているゴキブリですが
右の方のゴキブリは食べ続けて
巨大ゴキブリになってしまいました
どうしてだろう？ということで
ゴキブリの食欲を支配する機構に
私達は興味を移しまして
まず食べている状態と
飢餓になっている状態を
表すような信号になるような物質は何か
ということを追究しようと考えた訳です
そのためには消化管を取って来て
私が取ったのは1650匹取ったのですが
（笑）
ゴキブリの消化管を集めてすり潰して
アミノ酸がいくつか繋がった
「ペプチド」という成分を分けていって
100本ぐらい分けていって
それが消化吸収のためには
消化液が出てくるということも大事ですけど
食べた物を後ろに
送って行かないといけない訳ですよね
消化管をつり下げておくと
こうやって伸びたり縮んだりするんですけど
その100本分けたもの[ペプチド]から1本1本
この[消化管の]中に
分けたもの[ペプチド]を入れてやると
こうやって[伸び縮み]してたものが
ガガガッと動き出したり
伸びきって止まってしまったりとか
色々な物がそうやって出てくるわけです
そこで出て来た物が ここにあるような
「CCAP」というペプチドです
最終的に 純品というか
１個だけそのフラクションに入っている
ものを取る[ことによって]
どういうアミノ酸で出来ているか[を]
決定することができます
決定すると合成して
沢山作ることも出来るので
それを使ってCCAPというものが
ゴキブリの消化管の中で
何をやっているのか？
ということを
調べることが出来る訳です
そしてそういうことをやりました
そうすると
どういうことが起こるかというと
CCAPを系の中に入れると
消化管はガンガン動くし
もう一つは 物を食べると
消化しないといけないので消化酵素を出します
その消化酵素の分泌が促進されます
それから食べると
CCAPが組織の中にも沢山出来てくるし
体の中にも放出されてきます
もう一つ
反対側の機構はどうなっているか？
というので調べてやると
ここにある「sNPF」
というのが出てきました
sNPFは飢餓になると増加します
それでsNPFを体に注射してやると
消化酵素の分泌が抑制されます
ということでCCAPとsNPFは
飢餓と摂食の状態に対応して
減ったり増えたりする事に気がつきました
飢餓になっていると
sNPFが増えてくるんですが
もう一度食べさせると[sNPFが]下がって
CCAPが上がってくる
それから逆のことが
やっぱり起こります
ですからCCAPとsNPFは 互いに両方を
制御している物質であることが分かりました
その制御ですが
餌が体の中に入って来た時にそれを
どうやって認識するのかについては
例えば美味しいものを食べると
恍惚物質が出て来て
それで「消化管がんばれ」という
指令が出るのかもしれないし
喉を通る時に喉の運動で
消化管の運動が促進されるのかもしれない
消化管で認知するのかもしれないです
それを確かめるためには
どうすればいいか？
脳の役割を調べようとすると
脳を切ってしまえばいいんですね
そして切ってやれば
ここから下の方が袋に
なっているわけですから
色々な状態を作ることができます
栄養物は消化管にも入るし
血中にも入るし
ホルモンも同じですね
ホルモンも消化管の中にあるんですが
体液中にも出てくるわけです
そういうものを断頭したやつとか
しないやつとか
餌をお腹の中に注射器[で]打ったり
こんなとこに打ったりとか
色々な操作がゴキブリでは可能です
そういうものを 全般的に眺めてやることで
こういう機構があるだろうということが解りました
食べ物は消化管で認知されて
その信号は
消化管の中にある
青色のついた細胞で認知されます
すると その細胞が隣の細胞に起きろと
[命令して]ここにCCAPを放出してくる
もう一つは血中の中に放出する
これは例えば
消化酵素の量とかホルモンの量は
測定できますから
血中に出てるホルモンも測定できるし
組織の中のホルモンも測定できる
消化酵素はもちろん内腔という
穴の中に放出されるわけですが
そうすると隣の細胞は起きて
消化酵素は内腔という穴の開いた所に
放出すると消化が起こる訳です
ところが これで全てではなくて
このCCAPは消化管だけではなく
脳にもあります
それがどういう風にして動いているか
を探りにいきました
そうすると
こういうことが解かりました
消化管から出たCCAPは 脳に働いて
脳から大量のCCAPがまた放出されます
それが何故かというと
首を切ったら分かるんですね
首を切った時と切らない時というのは
血中に入ったCCAPが何を引き起こすか
脳を切っちゃった場合には
大量のCCAPは血中に現れてきません
ですから少量の
消化管から出ているCCAPが
脳を叩き起こして
脳から大量のCCAPを放出させる
そうすると消化管の中で
大量の消化酵素が放出される
このように いわゆる
起爆装置のような形で
血中に放出されたCCAPが
脳を引きずり出してきて
大量の消化酵素の分泌をするという
システムが明らかになってきました
一方で
そうしている機構の中で
ゴキブリはどういう行動をとるか？
というのが次のテーマです
脳から大量のCCAPが出てくると
ゴキさんは満腹感になって
寝てしまいます
こういう形で消化管の最初の—
車で言うとイグニッション
それから脳に行って
スターターが回ってエンジンがかかる
こういうポジティブフィードバック
正のフィードバック機構があることが
解りました
逆に飢餓になった場合はどうするか？
餌が無い時にはそれを
シャットダウンしなければならない
そうするとsNPFが出て来て
やっぱり脳から大量のsNPFが出てくると
ゴキ君はお腹が減って
餌の探索に走り回ることになります
CCAPが出てくると
sNPFが動かなくなって
sNPFが出ると
CCAPが出なくなる
こういうやじろべえがあるわけです
ですから 消化管の中で発火させて
正のフィードバックを動かし
かつ両方が抑制をかけて制御する
同時にこれはものを食べた後に
色んな付随する現象があります
餌があったら
繁殖にいってもいいし寝ててもいい
そういう色んなことが
餌を食べることに伴って起こります
餌が無い時には寝てたら
消耗してしまいますから 餌を探しに行く
そういう体全体の系が
こういう簡単な二つの物質のバランスで
制御されていることが解りました
私のメッセージは
昆虫から学ぼうということなんですけど
私達と昆虫は色んな点で
生理機能の制御とか遺伝子とか
そういったものを共有しているので
それを上手く利用することによって
私たちの生活の質も上がるし
環境にも良い政策が出来るだろう
そういうことで昆虫を
もっと利用していきましょう
昆虫は名前がついているだけで
100万種あるんです
ですから究極の多様性があります
昆虫のモデルとしての力
それから 資源としての力を
もうちょっと 利用して行ったらどうか
ということが私の提案です
今晩みなさん
台所でゴキブリに遭遇したら
スリッパで叩く前に
「サンキュー」と言ってやってください
（笑）
（拍手）
どうもお話を聞いて頂いてありがとう
サンキュー
（拍手）